for around 65 thousand years a community
known as the Terra tantalise lived on an
island in complete isolation uncontacted
and disconnected from the entire rest of
the planet their early ancestors had
become stuck on the island after the
land they were settled on separated and
moved further and further away from its
parent landmass over time the island
would drift sufficiently far enough away
that nothing could be seen from it other
than the vast ocean and a few other
small island rock formations after
thousands of years on their own the
island community had been able to
develop crude language filled small
fragile shelters and construct simple
tools but because of their isolated
nature limited resources and
evolutionary conditions they remain
mostly primitive in unintelligent
evolving at an extremely slow rate they
had no idea where they were or how they
got there they knew nothing other than
the island and the dome of the horizon
they believed they were stuck inside the
community was first discovered around
4,500 years ago when a ship undertaking
a transoceanic journey happened to cross
it around this time neighboring land
masses were being connected and
colonized for the first time
modern towns cities countries and
continents were forming and coming
together the island was relatively small
and appeared useless to those who first
discovered it and thus it was initially
passed by and left alone over the next
thousand years or so the island would be
discovered several more times it would
eventually become part of the territory
of the neighboring continent Laniakea
The Associated government believed it to
be advantageous to try and officially
colonize the island and attempt to form
mutual relations with the natives
however because they were still much
earlier on in their development like
most civilizations in their early stages
the Islanders were irrational violent
and defensive they frequently fought and
killed each other over food territory
mating partners power beliefs and
whatever else they could use as an
excuse and now because of the
particularly rash nature colonizers were
met with senseless violence and
aggression with no opportunity to
properly reason or communicate with them
the colonizers decided it was best to
leave them alone and not reciprocate
knowing how easily they could wipe the
entire island from existence over the
following number of years Rhea temps to
form relations with the Islanders would
occur several times
each time however colonizers were again
met with violence and an inability to
communicate to the inhabitants of the
island the colonizers were like aliens
who showed up out of the walls of the
horizon on massive incomprehensible
ships the Islanders had no words nor
concepts to grasp what was happening and
so they reacted against it on primal
impulse the discrepancy between the two
realities could simply not be reconciled
at the time ultimately the island was
small with nothing particularly
desirable and interactions had caused
all parties nothing but harm and so the
island would earn the reputation as one
of the most dangerous places on the
planet not because of its advanced
weaponry but because of the mere
temperament and low intelligence of the
population that lived on it mutual
relations were at least at the time
considered impossible and futile because
the island technically fell under the
jurisdiction of Laniakea The Associated
government made the determination that
it would be best to leave the island
alone an ordinance was established and
the community on the island was given
privacy and protective rights any
further unpermitted contact observation
and visitation would now become
prohibited without realizing it
individuals on the island during the
time of first contact were effectively
closing themselves off and changing the
entire course of their potential
civilization completely unaware that
they were causing anything at all let
alone something so significant and now
unbeknownst to them they were
technically a part of a colony and an
Intercontinental government order
restricted from any further outside
contact indefinitely they would soon
become one of the last unintegrated
civilizations the island slowly but
surely became forgotten by the rest of
the planet like lost unwanted children
they were to fend for themselves and
find their own way
for hundreds of generations thereafter
the Islanders never saw any members of
any other race causing them to believe
that there mustn't be any other races at
all signs of others like the occasional
passing ship or eventual airplanes and
helicopters were perceived merely as
unusual animals no different than the
bugs fish birds or mammals that popped
up on or around the island and any
modern items that washed ashore were
believed to be strange rock or plant
formations that floated up from the
ocean as more and more years would pass
though the Islanders slowly became more
intelligent improving their verbal and
social abilities and eventually
developing better technologies enhanced
applications of fire and combustion
theoretical thinking in more complex
language all created a feedback loop in
which new tools were created by the
Islanders and then the new tools created
new Islanders eventually individuals on
the island began to comprehend their
circumstances more accurately and
started to speculate about the walls of
the horizon they realized that perhaps
the horizon wasn't a wall or edge at all
they looked out at the ocean and at all
the little uninhabited islands they
could see in the distance and wondered
where is everyone
then they wondered that if they were
wondering this wouldn't that mean that
if anyone else was out there they would
also be wondering the same and if so why
hadn't anyone else ever tried to find or
contact them many Islanders began to
believe that they weren't alone but yet
there was no evidence that they weren't
and so many remained skeptical
ultimately they realized the options
were either they were alone on this
isolated floating rock where there were
others out there somewhere both
possibilities were equally terrifying
and awe-inspiring as more time passed
fueled by instinctual curiosity and the
yearning to branch out and connect with
the beyond the Islanders began to
dedicate time and resources to exploring
outward off the island
they began designing ship vessels tools
and weapons specific to discovery
missions as these new technologies
developed and brought on new
opportunities though they also brought
on new problems between the amount of
resources required from the island and
the increased deadliness of better
weaponry the Islanders were facing one
of the great filters that all developing
civilizations have to overcome surviving
the metamorphosis of their own self
without being aware of it they were
essentially in a race against themselves
either going to build the necessary
technologies to get everyone beyond the
island or destroy the island and kill
themselves in the process the early
shift vessels were weak
difficult to control several groups of
individuals were killed on the early
missions
slowly but surely though they would
begin to develop more advanced ships and
would soon visit each neighboring island
one by one starting at the closest and
then reaching a little further each time
eventually they reached the furthest
visible landmass fearful of going beyond
their vision and means of control and
understanding though they stopped going
any further while trying to build a ship
or device that could sustain and be
controlled long enough for a further
journey they put up devices on their
shorelines that produce sounds in hopes
that if anyone else was anywhere they
would hear their signals they also
constructed large funnels with a tube
narrowing down to the base in order to
listen for any potential incoming
messages from others who might be doing
the same of course
they heard nothing unusual and produced
nothing noticeable unaware that such
sounds were not being looked for and
would not be heard with any significance
with all immediate neighboring islands
being uninhabited and with no signs of
anyone from beyond the Islanders remain
confused as to why they appeared to be
alone why their island appeared to be
the only one that supported life of
course only about 1,100 miles west just
out of the Islanders reach was an entire
modern technologically advanced
civilization filled with other beings of
different races all engaged in an
interconnected order with the rest of
the planets of other modern
civilizations the island community would
exist with no more than a hunch that
they weren't alone unable to know that
the reason they had no evidence was
because of their own ancestors
throughout the years the island had been
occasionally checked on by the Laniakea
government however nothing had ever
really appeared to change much even
during the islands initial transition
into advancement it only appeared as if
they had built little structures or
musical instruments for themselves
nothing that warranted concern nor
intervening however one day many years
into their future after a tropical storm
caused for a checkup it was noticed that
there appeared to be a more advanced
piece of technology on the island who
was also noticed that the island
appeared to have a scare sness of
vegetation and was starting to dry up
completely
having realized what was likely
happening dropped down onto the shore
several days later was a box inside was
a white flag a set of instructions and a
letter written in every known language
which translated loosely into the
following dear friends we hope this
reaches you well please consider it a
peaceful introduction we have known
about you for quite some time now
fact we have met many of your ancestors
in the past we predict you have come a
long way since then we believe you might
be ready to meet us again we are not
that dissimilar our pasts were once the
same but somewhere along the lines we
became disconnected we think you might
be interested in ready to reconnect we
believe you might need to soon by the
looks of it you may not survive much
longer on your own there is a big planet
out there much of which you probably
won't understand right away but
eventually you will and eventually it
will all make sense
you will discover and experience things
that you could never even imagine right
now you will join us as we all survive
and forge onward together if you wish to
remain alone that is your right but we
have all gone through the same things in
some form or another
and we're always much better off
together than we are alone we hope
you're old enough to realize this now if
and when you are ready the rest of us
are ready for you best wishes signed the
rest of us
[Music]
you